hey guys what's up this is andrew for
jensenses.com so in this video guys
we're gonna go through amc gme price
action i'm also gonna go through triple
q oil market and as some of you
requested i'm gonna have a look at what
is happening on the crypto market so
let's get into it
all right guys so
uh another good day let's start with amc
so let me quickly remind you guys what i
was saying in my in the video i posted
yesterday so we were in a situation that
was good for a reversal we were once
again on the daily timeframe in
a consolidation so consolidation is kind
of easy to spot because it's just the
press action being contained in a tight
range after some move up or strong move
down so those considerations are
sometimes continuation patterns which
means that we can say that then we go
lower or sometimes there are reversal
patterns so uh once you spot a
consolidation
you can try to see what kind of signals
you have inside this constitution so
here we're having this bullish
divergence and i told you guys yesterday
that whenever you have a bullish
divergence then you try to look for
breakout or an rsi above 50. it's
working as well but you need to use the
proper time frame here the hourly time
frame is maybe
not best
the best to use the followers time frame
would be better and um
if you want to know which time frame to
use once again guys this is uh
discretionary this will depend on every
trader i'm sharing everything that i
personally do in the course that is once
again available if you click on the link
in the description of this video and
right now guys you can have the course
for only 150 us dollars uh you only
gonna have the book where you have uh
also also the step by step method that i
give you guys which is give which is
basic where where basically all the
information is contained so
for those who don't want to spend too
much money and don't really want to have
all the videos because if you take the
big course you're going to have the same
information but with eight hours of
video so um
i explain everything there about how to
choose the time frame here the first
time frame would be more appropriate to
me um and either you look for breakout
or an rsi above 50. so here you can see
on the first time frame the rsi touched
50 and got rejected all right but we had
the breakout on the hourly timeframe and
i told you guys yesterday that this
signal is good but not perfect it's good
because we have a bullish divergence we
have a breakout uh and we are in a
situation where we are
waiting for a move up to come so this
was making sense but we didn't have the
volume if you don't have the volume the
breakout is not reliable and it makes
the price action a target for bears so
this is what happened here this is the
reason why i didn't post any alert in my
discord on
on this signal uh as you can see we went
close to the 19
resistance and then we got at the open
strongly rejected all right once again
on low volume so um to me we are still
in this you know
i would say longer consideration um i
still have hope that this breakout will
give us uh a reversal because
uh you can measure it's always the same
technique guys whenever you have a
breakout you measure the last move up
and you don't want the press action to
go below the 61.8 percent retracement so
here the 61.8 retracement for the
bullish momentum created by the breakout
to be intact and here it's at 17.7 so we
went slightly below and as you can see
we had a bullish reaction around 17.5
and right now we are consolidating
around this 17.8
support that is a bit resistance now so
you know there is a fight between booze
and best so let's see
this situation
would look bullish to me if
we had in the move up strong moves with
volume and in the move down low volume
and small moves so here we had low
volume on the way up which is not good
here we had an increase in volume at the
close that was kind of a
rather good sign to me
but what i don't like is to see a strong
move down like that okay whenever moves
are strong
it means that the price action is
developing in a clean way it means that
um
here that bears are leading so on the
very short term
so i have mixed signals some i would say
neutral still between like uh
a little bit bullish let's be honest
thanks to this um
breakout and as you can see the
trendline gave us a nice re-test as well
so
it's still very possible that we push
higher but once again this strong
rejection is not a good sign and it's
um you know giving you a bad sentiment
to bulls so let's see what's going to
happen here um i think that we still
need to have the strong move up with
volume for both to take back control for
now we didn't have it and it's also
related to what is happening on the rest
of the market
so let's have a look at the rest of the
market then i'm gonna do gme of course
we're exactly in the same situation guys
i showed you yesterday guys i uh
personally bought some triple q here at
not exactly here at
basically where my support is just below
at 337.4
uh i wanted to take profit at 449.5
i didn't get done so it's a pain in the
ass because i was making some good money
here uh i'm still positive uh but
but basically it's not a good day for me
because i'm losing money here
i'm losing money on amc
i'm losing money on gme i'm going to
show you that guys and i'm also losing
money on the oil market so sometimes
everything is going against you it's not
a good day for me
but this is trading you always you know
have this kind of moves um
so you just need to stick to the plan i
have stop losses i know whenever i want
to reload on the upside or the downside
so i feel good even if i lose money i
don't panic i know what to do
i just stick to my plan so uh triple q
we were in the same situation guys i
showed you that yesterday we had this
breakout that was good but once again
no volume so it's not a strong breakout
and same thing guys it got rejected i
wanted to sell here i was a seller here
but we didn't reach my target so this is
not a good sign whenever targets are not
reached it means that you know bears are
slightly ahead of the resistances it
means that there are confident in what
they do so it's not a good sign we got
rejected same thing as foreign as you
can see we found support here damn sorry
we found support here and for triple q
we found support here so it's exactly
the same thing and we can measure as
usual guys we're gonna measure the last
move up bam bam bam and oh surprise
exactly on the 61.8 fib ratio
so surprising
so
what does it tell us
it tells us that
that there is still hope this move up
continues but once again as you can see
guys look where are the biggest scandal
coming here are they coming on the
upside or the downside i mean we then
gonna have a look at the volume but
first look at the candles we have here
one nice candle second one nice candle
but this candle is bigger than
everything else we've seen before so
that's not good we want to see small
moves on the downside on low volume big
moves on the upside with strong volume
so of course um it's quite rare to see
those movements developing perfectly but
it's just what we want to see to be kind
of sure that bulls and control here have
mixed signals have a breakout with that
volume
uh we didn't reach the resistance and we
got rejected before that so this is
bearish breakout is bullish bullish uh
divergence is bullish so three so let's
first focus on the bullish things
buddhist divergence breakout
uh
that's pretty much it and uh for the
uh bearish uh signals we didn't reach
the 350 resistance got rejected before
and we're moving with bigger moves on
the downside so it's like 50 50 as you
can see i'm still rather bullish here
just
because it makes more sense to me when i
check my elliott waves so this is you
know the last thing to do you first need
to check the dynamics volume volatility
momentum
and then you try to fit this into an
alienwave analysis which is structuring
the moves of the market so that's not an
easy game but this is the way the
in this order things should be done
without elliott wave you can trade with
that volume volatility momentum you
cannot trade all right i mean you can
trade but just go to casino it's gonna
be the same uh it's even gonna be acting
easier in the casino so um here
to conclude
neutral same thing the bullish momentum
has been broken i don't know what's
gonna happen uh i'm having my stop
losses still around three three five i
think i'm gonna lift my stop loss a
little bit higher guys because at least
i'm gonna lock in this trade with some
profit so i think i'm gonna put my stop
loss the stop-loss can be basically put
between the 61.8 and 78.6 all right so
roughly between those two uh this is a
good area for the stop plot if you if
you really want to be conservative you
put your stop-loss below the low but as
you can see you're going to risk much
more so the risk reward is going to be
worse and as long and whenever we go
below the uh 6 61.8
fib ratio the probability of a strong
rebound is diminishing so i'm totally
fine to getting stopped in this area
personally this is what i've been doing
for many years and i think that this is
the right way to trade of course
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
but here uh this is what i'm going to do
i'm going to put
i'm going to lift my stop loss from 335
to here and i'm gonna announce it in my
discord i didn't do it yet because for
now i want to see
i want to see what's going to happen i
see this bullish reaction at the 61.8
percent so it gives me hope that um that
we just go higher so for now i don't do
anything uh and we're gonna see what's
gonna happen but basically yes as you
can see the correlation is very close to
one between amc and triple q
so uh this is gonna go together guys uh
it it went together for the past week
it's going to go together probably for
the next week
so it's good to have different
i would say scenarios based on different
assets but that you know you can combine
in the end and here i have pretty much
the same analysis in this particular
case it's not very useful i would like
to have for example much stronger
signals on triple q
i don't have it i'm rather neutral when
i look at bullish versus bearish signs
so
rather bullish guys let's be honest it's
a little bit bullish thanks to this
breakout a breakout even if it's not
reliable is still a breakout so
uh so i keep faith guys i think that uh
the
the reversal is still on the way
it would be good to have a close you
know
you can look as well at the moving
averages but same thing you need to
choose the right time frame but you can
see that here the 50 period moving
average was clearly acting as a
resistance in the move down
especially in the consolidation so we
want to close above that level we here
had a breakout above the 18 level above
this blue trend line and above the 20 50
day uh sorry our
simple moving averages so
uh we then
found some support here they are here
guys they are exactly where the uh
support is at so resistance support i'm
not sure 17.8 so we would like to close
above those two hourly moving average so
roughly above
18.07
if we close above that today
booze are still in control to me on the
short term but not by far so let's find
out guys jimmy
dming is almost flat so as usual guys
jimmy's you know showing strength uh
it's very
this is for example good to combine
jimmy and amc because in the whole uh
move down that amc did for the past two
three weeks jimmy was stronger so this
was this is was one of the reasons why i
was still thinking all right balls and
control booze and control uh when i look
just an amc clearly boos are no more not
in control anymore below 21 as i showed
you many times before guys the 61.8 of
this first move up is at 21. so since we
broke out below this level burst to back
control
by the way i fixed my audio guys so hope
this is good now i'm so sorry that it
was really bad for three videos
something like that um but i finally you
know i looked uh for some tutorials and
i had many issues to fix it but i
finally found those solutions so let me
know if you still have some issues with
the audio but i think it's gonna be good
uh and blah blah blah yeah here here
below 21 i said we start bears win
control but on jme guys as you can see
we are still holding well above
the
61.8 percent of this
massive massive move up
so here we go we found support at the
fifty percent uh fib ratio we still have
room guys so
for me gme is still bullish and
i mean quite by a lot all right this
once again movement that we had here is
absolutely perfect i'm not going to go
through that again but it's respecting
fib ratio it's like you know a very
strong third wave with a massive volume
so whenever you have something like that
i mean bears remember and whenever booze
are going to start to attack for now
they're not attacking look at the volume
it's very
low but whenever they're going to attack
buzz are going to be scared because they
remember what happened to them
last month and this memory is going to
last for quite some time because it was
a clear clear victory
and
i think that bears know that they're in
danger and you know they're gonna
probably
uh buy back their short positions uh i'm
not talking about the structural bears
i'm talking about some day trader that
to take
bearish positions those guys they're
gonna probably stop the position quite
early um and they're gonna participate
in the move up that uh might happen
anytime guys seriously we are in a nice
environment for those moves up to happen
uh we just need i think the global
market to be stronger guys minus one
percent today is not good
um
we need this market to be bullish and if
it is then amc and gme will probably
be the best performers
amongst all the stocks
so we're going to find out guys uh what
else can i tell you on gme yesterday i
was telling you guys here this
152 level
that has been broken here with low
volume then bears attacked the breakout
that was uh you know a breakout to
attack let's be honest on very low
volume
then here
same thing um
bulls attacked this downside breakout
that was here so we had a double fake
out fake out here fake out here and then
i told you we are back in this range and
to me we are still in this range that is
uh the
that is the the consideration that is
the range where the consolidation is
taking place and above which it we need
to break out to uh for both to take back
control so the last hour is very nice
guys as you can see so of course i'm
posting that
three hours before market closed so
let's see where we're gonna close but if
we're able uh yesterday i was telling
you guys that we want to close above 150
because i wanted this breakout to happen
we didn't go through that by the way so
let's go through this because uh
i i i saw that this morning i mean i saw
that yesterday night uh but we didn't
analyze it together so let's have a look
at that bracket what do you guys think
all right look at that
so i'm talking about this breakout so
let me get rid of that breakout first
pump
okay
so what do you think of this breakout
guys
is it a good breakout so let's analyze a
good breakout happens after a nice
consolidation on low volume with
increasing volume we need and uh and
a strong move so here it was not a
strong move it happened on low volume
and it happened after consideration of
only three candles so this is not a very
good breakout but it's still a breakout
we're still happy to see that uh most
breakouts are not perfect breakouts and
they still give good results so of
course it's better to go to those who
are that are perfect so that you
increase your efficiency ratio
but if you want just to you know
build your view and you know try to
guess where the market will go every
breakout is for me a good bullish sign
or bearish if it's on the downside
so here we have this breakout and as you
guys can see typical thing breakout then
we uh came to this 152.3 level uh and
got rejected here so this is like i said
guys still resistance is still the
resistance for me to close above on the
daily timeframe then we got rejected
once again brutally guys with a strong
move uh but it happened together with
the global market so it's not a gme
related issue
we found support uh on the trend line uh
as usual guys we found support here and
now we are moving higher so that's
pretty good you know what i'm gonna do
right now of course i'm gonna measure
the pullback
okay
once again yes yummy strong you saw
triple q 61.8 amc 61.8 gme
38.2 papa 147 guys
i mean
this is showing you once again that on
the short on the on the low time frame
on a higher time frame whatever gme is
stronger pullbacks are a boat quicker so
this is very very reassuring to me does
it mean that we can't go lower no but
it's just good to see that i'm happy to
see this and it gives me hope for
amc and the rest of the market
so uh all right so i think i'm done guys
on gme let's see if we're able to have
this
daily close
as you can see guys i keep my level here
because
this is the level right i mean it's on
the hourly timeframe you don't really
know where is the resistance on the
daily timeframe it's very obvious guys
look one reaction two reactions
three reactions and as i'm explaining my
course you can sometimes use close or
highs depending on what give is giving
you the best reactions and here you can
see the close was at
152.5 okay
fine i'm gonna put my trendline here
because i want to have something that
never happened before we already have
had a close above 152.3 so so let's say
that now it's
152.5 is the level to close above
152.55 is good because it's something
that never happened in the past week
so if we close above that level
to me it's gonna be one more reason for
bulls to buy tomorrow so let's find out
let's see what's gonna happen if it
happens next resistance is 160 we have
the 200 day moving average coming 160.2
so something
okay we're gonna analyze that later guys
uh we're not here okay let's analyze
maybe it's gonna happen tomorrow it can
happen anytime so let's be prepared if
you guys are interested to know where
are the resistances
yeah it's here 150 why is it here guys
you saw i went on the first time frame
bam one high one high one low so it's
the trendline that is giving me the most
uh reactions so i'm putting it here then
i go on the daily time frame i check if
it fits well
and it's fitting not too bad we have the
200-day moving average slightly above
this resistance let me put it in orange
bam bam bam
okay
uh so
okay the 200-day moving average would
probably come here sooner or later uh
and so
a move that makes sense is something
like that and here we see what happens
okay
so bam bam bam
tick tick tick
up
okay
so this is a scenario that makes sense
and then 159 would be the resistance so
let's see if we're able to go through
that first we need to go through 152.5
then uh we're gonna see if we're able to
go above 159 which will also be the
200-day moving average why do i have to
make d2 macd is useless okay
so that's it for gme guys and i can tell
you
again what is the um
what are we looking for guys we're
looking for a third wave oh i don't have
it here anymore but we're looking for
that
okay just for everyone to
you know keep in mind what we are trying
to to uh
to achieve here we're trying to make
this third wave
uh real because
it's been a long time guys i'm having
this
extremely bullish scenario here
uh i still believe it can happen but it
cannot happen in a bear market so we
need to have triple q stronger we need
to have good news uh coming from the fed
we need to have good news coming from
the war i mean
you know things can't you you can't have
that strong moves up in a market that is
moving sideways you need a strong bull
market and let's see let's see it's
possible once again the macro economics
are not good
but you know the market is
forward-looking right so if there is
hope that next year on two years
companies are gonna make money then uh
investors can uh still buy and all this
money that has been injected in the
economy that has actually created guys
this meme stock movements right uh
everybody was starting to buy you know
undervalued stocks that were just
destroyed by hedge funds um and this
could happen because of this money that
was injected in the economy so right now
we are tappering which means that um
there is a buyback of this
assets that is going to start uh
i think it's
it has started in less months but it's
it's very low okay you can check it here
uh you tap fed son we
okay bam and we're gonna see what is how
if the fed has started to buy back or
not you just click here the first link
is it here so we fed
so i think we're around 7 billion us
dollars injected
where is it it's not here
so you tap fed somewhere balance [ __ ]
okay we're gonna find it guys
place it here
okay
okay bye you see
[Laughter]
nine billion all right that was i said
seven is recent balance sheet trends am
i looking at the right thing yeah guys
here you see so this is data from april
six so this is a tapering as you can see
here this was to wait we started to
print and this was the kovid we printed
uh you know more than we have ever
printed before in the whole history of
financial markets in you know a few
months all right we went from 4 billion
to
7 billion in a few months then from 7
billion to almost 9 billion and this is
the tapering i don't know if you see
well guys
but
okay
okay so this is what is happening right
now okay
you can see we are still
injecting money in the economy
but
we're gonna be flat soon and then we're
gonna start to sell all right so as long
as this money is here
everything that happened during this
money injection which uh for example our
squeezes
can still happen uh because this process
is taking some time so we can still have
some massive moves up on the global
market and on the beam stocks happening
in the coming six months
after that guys let's be honest i don't
think we're gonna be in an environment
where this is still gonna happen so we
have roughly six months maybe one year
left for crazy moves to happen on the uh
global market and uh on uh the crypto
market and on meme stocks oh okay so i'm
done here guys and i said that i will
talk about crypto so just quickly on oil
oil is getting dumped little bit today
but rather flatish uh same thing guys
break out on low volume so it got
rejected by bears here guys
um
and we are right now coming back on this
at the 61.8 retracement of the last move
up so
this scenario is still making sense to
me i'm personally uh having a big
position here
um
the market is doing better right now i
don't want to look at my pnn guys today
it was not nice you know those days when
you know you make money for two weeks or
three weeks and then in one day yes you
lose almost everything you made because
you you know you're greedy you increase
your position i hope i'm not gonna be
wrong on that guys i need the market to
go up i need all to go up i need amc to
go up and i think it's gonna happen guys
for now it's still good and i have no
problem to stop my position not amc of
course but on oil and the global market
if things don't go my way
and i have my stop-losses already placed
of course so that i don't panic i'm
relaxed
but i'm still not happy i'm losing money
today
whatever so bitcoin uh bam bam bam so
here are my three scenarios so i'm gonna
go quickly guys because i don't want to
make these videos too long
but here the situation is what
okay
big move down fair enough why i have to
make dinner again
big move down okay as usual then
the momentum starting to go higher
all right which shows that we are in a
good situation for reversal
uh
the market making
not lower lows here so we we don't have
a bullish divergence
so maybe this is only a corrective you
know consideration that is going to be
followed by a strong move down okay this
is this scenario here is the scenarios i
built uh last week so i'm going to keep
it and we're going to see if we follow
one of those
um
so
what can i tell you here yes so we were
consolidating guys for the past month
and as usual guys we're looking for
breakout we had a breakout here and i
told you in my discord guys uh we can
have a look together bam bam bam
okay so this was this breakout that
happened on the 25th of march 25th of
march i said we have a breakout above
the triangle without volume which is
very similar to what happened on june
13th
blah blah blah before bitcoin made a new
law and then only bounced for good so i
said that we're gonna sell this breakout
and i posted a few selling orders at 45
46 48 and 51 i got executed on two of my
selling orders and then i bought back
lower
right now what i did guys
i i sold 42
um i sold 42 i bought back a little bit
too early let's be honest i was playing
a rally so i bought back the 38.2 around
43.42 and now i'm selling back what i
bought around the same levels
because i didn't like to have this
strong move down here that happened on
april 11th all right support trendline
did and all this is what i'm saying
uh you see this one
okay this which was the uh breakout
trend line okay the the breakout is here
so for the breakout to be validated and
reliable we need to stay above the 61.8
percent fee ratio of course but we also
need to stay above the trend line uh
that has been broken during the breakout
so here whenever i saw that
i said okay i'm placing my selling
orders at 42. so now
i i sold some of my position at 42
and it looks like we are going towards
the blue scenario for now
as you can see i posted that here so i
said that
green and blue scenarios that were to me
the best scenarios is that first we go
to 42 then either we break it retest go
higher or get rejected
it's not sure we're gonna get rejected
but for now we are rejected so
depending on what's going to happen on
the rest of the market once again this
is going to go together if triple q
holds above 338
i don't see a reason why bitcoin would
uh really go lower we can see
as well how deep this move has
retraced and we can see that we went to
the
61.8 so you you don't know if you should
take this one or this one let's take the
whole move up here because it's feeling
better
um
it's here there is no good answer i mean
naturally i would have taken the last
move up which is here but this is also
one big move up so whatever we are
roughly uh we found support at the 61.8
retracement which was at 39 700.
um so it's still possible that we are
going to follow the green
scenario i give you 20 chance guys not
big 25 maybe so it's also the same
probability i give to the triple q going
to uh new highs
and to amc squeezing right now guys it's
25 roughly so it's not big but if it
happens guys the reward is that big
that's it's a good trade in expectations
right right we're here to um make the
trades that are good in terms of
expected p l and whenever the
probability is 25 but the gain can be
times 10
i mean you do the math right it's a very
good expected p l of around two
so um
with 200
uh so here depending on
off your initial investment so here um
i don't know what to tell guys uh i
would say that we have 25 chance to go
higher if we break out above 42 000 then
probably i would probably buy the retest
at 42 because i don't want to miss this
rally um
i didn't sold sell off my all of my
position by the way the most likely
scenario is the blue one
guys is that after we broke out here i
said
it looks a little bit like what happened
in june like here guys we have the same
situation breakout with low volume and
then we made a new low all right twice
and then only we came back with increase
in volume as you can see here all right
guys so this is what we're looking for
and for now we don't have it so are we
gonna make a new low i don't know maybe
um
i would say that there is a 50 chance
that we make
even a 70 chance we make a new low from
here
uh
and there is a 20 20 percent chance that
we have really a strong move down and
that we go back to the 28 000 level i
don't see bitcoin going below the 28 000
level because
um
because it's a very bullish market and i
don't know to me the support is strong
so of course it can happen but it's not
even in my scenarios to me the worst
case scenario is 28 i'm going to be a
buyer here of course
um
so yeah that's it 42 000 resistance
support 39 750 next support 37 000 so if
you guys want to buy
uh
39 737
other levels i would be personally
watching at you also have thirty four
thousand and twenty eight thousand so
the my levels are here guys for those
who want to average down not financial
advice but here are my support levels
so
to conclude i think that we still need a
little bit of time maybe a month or two
depending on which scenario we take
before seeing the volume coming back and
finally a strong rally so that's it for
today i hope you guys enjoyed this video
and if you did please don't forget to
click on the sub like and bell button so
you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to shore see you guys